soon this meal alhamdulillah
assalamualaikum which is greeting a
peace peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the Dean show today
we're going to be discussing Islam and
global warming something that is
affecting us all the environment we want
to know a little bit about what Islam
has to say about this issue and how
would the last and final messenger sent
to mankind the Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him how would he
solve this issue of global warming so
our next guests who were going to bring
out it's not dr. Phil this is dr.
Muhammad module to help us former
professor from the John Hopkins
University dr. Nyland again how are you
please have a seat shake please have a
seat you here on the Dean show and we're
gonna cut to a break and we're gonna be
back here with the special guess you
don't want to go nowhere right back
I love there's only one word a Mohammad
is His Messenger Allah like in the world
o Allah there's only one bed and Jesus
was his messenger Allah no I did that
maybe it maybe it's just to break the
ice assalamu alaikum I don't know what
the line how are you playing time to lie
about to you I'm do lots of fellas now
we're here to discuss this issue of
global warming absolutely tell us how
would the last and final messenger first
before we go there tell us a little bit
what does this mean for the layman who
he hears his term but he's not quite
familiar what does this mean global
warming talk to us yeah global warming
it's very simple the word global and the
we're warming which if you combine them
together it becomes that the increase of
the average temperature around the globe
because of air pollution because of
carbon dioxide and other elements in
because of the global warming there's a
lot of changes in the environment a lot
of changes in the weather and if you
keep tracking the weather in the last
few years because it began almost 60
years ago and it's still continuous
there's a change in the weather for
example in January we expect to see very
severe weather in some areas in the
world but nowadays you sometimes they
are war and the weather is there is warm
or changing so this change mix
everything upside down yeah because of
that now there is a leader there is a
man a teacher who was set just like God
Almighty the crater he's the guide he
sent these messengers to teach us how to
live on this earth now tell us the last
and final messenger sent a man kind of
problem how the peace be upon him how
would he solve this issue that we're
having talk to us please yeah thank you
first of all before I elaborate on the
Prophet salah salem and his role in
solving these global problems in the
world i would love to remind people that
Islam is not just a religion Islam is a
way of life so from this you can
understand that it addresses everything
there is a solution for every problem
that happens there is a way that we can
handle
we can live with whatever changes that
are happening in the world our role that
we can do in order to solve these
problems almost every aspect of life is
addressed in Islam under Islam as Islam
as a way of life nothing's been left out
not nothing otherwise there would be
something wrong with the religion yeah
it makes sense because Allah Allah Allah
created the religion for people sent
Emmanuel to them to guide them how to
behave and what to do in order to
protect the place that they live in how
to deal with the neighbors have to deal
with neighboring countries how to deal
with the weather how to deal with the
environmental changes in everything
because it's a way of life otherwise
there would be something missing in the
religion which is impossible in the
religion of Islam because it's the final
religion that a Lost Planet Alison to
all mankind to protect them and to
preserve them so you can understand that
Islam provides services for all human
beings even if they are not Muslims they
still can deal with these problems in
the Islamic way and by themselves they
will see the effect of using this
Islamic techniques in their life yeah
let me go back to the leader of the
leaders that you mentioned yeah we're
prophet and Messenger Muhammad peace be
upon him salala wasilla he dealt with
these issues of course we wouldn't say
that he was a Superman dealing with
these issues from his perspective rather
he was dealing from these issues from a
divine perspective from a divine message
from Almighty Allah subhana Allah that
was brought to him by gibril so I was
teaching people because of the message
that he got from Almighty Allah and this
message of course is the final message
so it's very comprehensive let me tell
you that try to imagine that the person
who was living 1400 years ago in the
desert of Mecca and the desert of Arabia
was thinking of something that is
considered one of the solutions for
global warming one of the causes of
global warming is that the green areas
of the line
and is cut off which led to a change in
the weather yes to the prophet
sallallahu a salem this long time 1400
years ago was teaching people how to
increase the green lands not just in
Arabia almost everywhere and he was keen
to change this land the desert into a
Greenland so this is one of his not just
dreams but he were one of his teachings
to all the Muslims in one of his famous
statements or hadith that he taught the
Muslims he said that mamun Muslim yes
rouser on a we already saw her son fea
kuruman who in sanam I'll Tyron Baba
hematin it Allah can at lavaca let me
just give you brief translation of this
it's not a single Muslim who would plant
a tree or a bush or makes any
cultivation and this leads to a human
being eat from it or a bird eats from it
or an animal aids from it and less this
would considered a blessing and a reward
and the charitable act for him so now
you see the the genius of the prophets
allah salam here he linked it a worldly
life thing issue that benefits us in
life but at the same time it's connected
with later life it's connected with the
reward that a Muslim would take because
of that so not only Muslims should do
services to humans in this earth but at
the same time if they do that of course
they get some benefits in the world but
at the same time they get the reward
from Almighty Allah you can see from
this statement as well the prophets
allah silence is not only talked about
the benefit to humans but also to birds
and animals as well so this great
religion does not only address issues
that are related to human beings but
even animal so it does tell you that
islam and it does tell you that
salala Holly cell cares about humans
cares about animals kurz about a
complete balance hopefully no one's left
a complete package the you either take
it off it covers everything in life
amazing just try to imagine a person in
the desert who is thinking of that how
important the earth to be green this is
just one of the details of the proofs of
many many proofs and while it was ID'd a
messenger from the Creator absolutely
this is eyeing that is a messenger of
creator and this is a message from
Almighty Allah is to keep the earth
green of course Allah subhana Allah can
make it green in a moment or in a second
but a las planet Allah wants human
beings to work to do an act to make an
effort in this life otherwise they would
be lazy waiting and watching and but
they're lost planet Allah wants people
to do something and he would reward them
for that thing again when you look at
this hadith from many perspectives you
can see how the Prophet sallallahu Salem
although he I would say that he never
went to a Greenland like like some parts
of the USA or europe or other countries
that were agreed you most of his life
was in Arabia and the desert of Arabia
sometimes with palm trees very little
green thing but he's so the importance
of this thing in their life in the life
of the Muslim because it has not even
even the color the green color itself it
has a psychological impact on the hearts
of human beings shake we're going to
this is very exciting and the ears are
glued to the screen people are very
excited we have to take a break we're
going to be right back to cover continue
covering this topic you don't wanna go
nowhere peace be unto you welcome back
to the Dean show we are here with dr.
Muhammad mock do yes how are you lying
so I'm a conoco selling one you've
written a lot of books also we're not
going to be talking a little bit about
those author of ten different books John
happens you former professor John
Hopkins University's how
forgive you just tell us briefly how
long have you really been indulging all
your time and effort into this wonderful
way of life Islam and teaching the
people i think as a muslim born in a
Muslim family yeah that I've been
enjoying this great religion see since I
was born yes since I found that my
parents selected a good name for me a
name that I am proud of a name that
relates me to the great messenger of
this religion muhammad sallallahu
wasallam seeing my parents my family in
my appearance and my brothers and
sisters practicing Islam when I was
young I got used to that and they used
to have more beauty every day because
they trained me too fast in the
beginning in the early ages and they
trained me and Leah coached me to makes
a lot and to enjoy all the beautiful
aspects of this great religion and I am
proud to be a Muslim and I thank Allah
span or Tyler who gave us who gave me
this blessing to be born as a Muslim and
to keep doing that and hamdullah because
of my relationship with scholars and
seeking knowledge and every day I would
discover something about this great
religion for example the personality of
the prophet salallahu is elements and
it's unlike all other leaders of the
realm the more you dig in to dig deep
into the personality of the prophets
allah the more you find the pearls and
the treasures in it unlike other people
when they have relationship with you for
a long time the more i know you the more
i discover some of your weaknesses is a
natural thing because we are human here
here's the opposite here is the opposite
picture totally when you deal with the
prophet salah salem everyday you see one
of his statements one of his how he
treated the Jews how he treated the
Christians and he welcomed the
Christians in his mastered and yet there
are many beautiful things that every day
you say oh this is a great man with it
after some time when you read something
else about him in his biography you find
that he is far greater than the image
that you used to have like
deeper and deeper now absolutely
absolutely it's an ocean of knowledge
and beautiful aspect and and this is my
message to everybody I want you to spend
some time reading about this map and you
will definitely come up with the
conclusion that he is the leader of the
leaders or the best human beings not
just alone because allah subhan allah
tala selected him because of these
qualities but because really in practice
you would find no other leader have come
up even close to his level or caliber
yeah before we went to a break you were
making some good points can you
elaborate on these yes going back to the
issue of making the land cream you find
you understand from this statement of
the prophet salallahu selim that he
tried to make it a job or a mission or a
task for every individual for example
other leaders would think of why
shouldn't we have a Department of
Agriculture or a Ministry of Agriculture
others would say that why shouldn't we
make some organizations that take care
of that which are very beautiful things
but the prophets along I shall I wanted
to handle it from the route from the
infrastructure the prophets allah is
Elam wanted to embed this to cultivate
this approach in the heart of every
Muslim and muslimah and every human
being as well if this can be done by
Muslims definitely it can be done by
non-muslims as well so who wanted to
address the issue on an individual level
because an individual not only and it is
not a task that can be done once and
forever and that's it no it's an ongoing
process every time you do cultivation or
you plant something you are rewarded by
Almighty Allah and this means that you
want to increase this as much as
possible there is one element here I
want you to imagine that okay people in
Arabia or desert or if you do that they
do that are they would use water a lot
of water definitely to make plantation
and this is again an invitation for
people to make research how to save
water right in cultivation and now we
have many examples that we cultivate by
drops of water coming from some tubes
there are many ways of that and here's
the embedded message that we can make
research in that not only that the
prophets allah salem in one of his
statement very famous statement he's
asking and the Muslims to save water as
much as possible look at this example
the example of salat in order to perform
this a lot the Muslims do they will do
the cleaning they clean themselves the
cleanliness and we force the law five
times a day if needed and sometimes it
may be less because you can combine two
prayers together or you can keep your
word oh so the prophets of Allah sell
and give an example you can make your
dough this cleaning by this amount of
water which is almost a water that fills
this cup yeah just try to imagine that
how much is saving nowadays if people
don't know this rule and this advice of
the prophets allah salam the waste a lot
of water and this again we considered
against the teaching of the prophet
sallallaho because water is needed
everywhere if it is not needed in this
area it may be needed in another area
but people underworld and I think that a
lot of scholars talking about that
perhaps the coming wars I hope this
doesn't he would it be the case that the
coming wars would be because of the
scarcity of water things that we don't
think about an oppression silicon on us
conserve these things yeah try to
imagine the person who is talking about
these issues is a person who lived 1,400
years ago but the message message here
is still vivid still vibrant still be
beneficial for all human beings and a
technique that can be used by every
human being anywhere in the world just
we need to have anything that we need to
have some classes in the secondary
school if not elementary school how to
teach our kids to have this spirit and
this love and this passion for the
Greeners and train them and coach them
to plant and to cultivate even little
things and I think by doing this we will
increase the amount of oxygen and we
hope that the whole picture would change
and this global warming would be
positively insha Allah going to the
right way of solving this problem tell
us you have not only Muslims talking
about this mighty man that lived but
there are many quotes and I heard you
mention one by a famous historian orator
that you know Muhammad peace be upon him
last of phenomena said to mankind he
would solve these issues that were
having today by drinking a keg
absolutely elaborate yeah one of the one
of the many people who talked about
positively about prophet mohamed salah
salem and and the reason that they were
positive they were not biased when they
read the biography clear prophets class
Allah they didn't have anything in the
background rather they wanted to be fair
to a person when you read a biography
were person without any biases you would
come up to the right conclusion one of
them was Bernard Shaw and I am quite
sure that is none too many viewers that
one of his statement he said that I have
known this man quite well and I've read
his biography and i'm quite sure had he
been alive nowadays he would have solved
the problems of the world wiley is
drinking a cup of tea amazing an amazing
statement a very statement that even
less than the level and the caliber of
the prophets allah salam but it really
shows that a man with this caliber is
not just a super man he's not but this
is instructed by Almighty Allah and the
Prophet himself was so humble too not to
attribute all these great things to
himself rather he would attribute it to
Almighty Allah who would say that it was
given to me I was taught by Almighty
Allah to do this and this so we talked
about dr. mundo we talked about planning
the seeds we've talked about making the
earth more green we talked about
conserving water tell us some more
things
the last I found a messenger sent to
mankind the problem and peace be upon
him instructor and gave advice for us to
do there's a lot but anyway I was
talking about two issues here one issue
is that not only the Prophet salah salem
was proactive and giving some initiative
and some advice and tips for people to
make the earth green but also even at
times of war the prophet salallahu you
sellin muhammad peace be upon him he
instructed his people and his followers
even at the time of war there is no
excuse for anyone to cut a tree or to
burn a green error area or to attack and
whistling a non-muslim woman or and a
child or an old man even a time of war
and if you just compare this approach
with the approaches of the leaders at
time of wars when they use all these
destructive weapons that kill without
seeing that killed all than the young
and the innocent and the compact the
only one from the Islamic perspective is
to be fought is the combating army yeah
but not anyone else even the land the
green there is no excuse you for burning
them and you can see and you can convert
compare that with what happened in where
did word one or where it were two or in
any other world that this was the
approach of the prophets allah salam
even a time that you can need you can
make a strategic decision to save your
army or your people your not allowed to
attack the earth or burn the greenland
look at this his his tip his advice to
people and wonderful hadees and scholars
would elaborate on it he said that if
the hour meaning the day of judgment the
day of resurrection that happens and
this is an unshakable belief among the
muslims that if it's going to happen and
if you have a bush in your hand and you
are about to plant it and the hour
started and the earthquake is continuing
and you know that everybody is going to
die if you can plant it before you stand
up do that if you can plant it before
you die do it it's an amazing thing the
prophets allah salam knows that the
people are going to die and the person
knows that he's going to die however he
wants to make the earth green he wants
to be positive in every aspect of life
and these are some examples of his tips
that would not only benefit human beings
but benefit others as we said that
animals and insects and all these
creatures that a las 10 dolla created
them this is truly amazing this is
something that any sincere person who's
coming up select this with an open mind
and open heart yeah and he looks at we
can go on and on with all the different
top scientific facts and this proof and
that proved but even this detail that
you discuss with preserving the
environment that we live in protecting
not only human beings animals but even
the earth yeah this is astonishing this
is amazing yeah and anyone to think in
this direction this was done and said
1400 years ago not a hundred years ago
to 1400 years of gain entry fees by a
man living in a desert absolutely there
wasn't much green there was it yeah yeah
so I tell us now if you can leave us
with something that will really
especially for those who are looking who
are not Muslim yet but they like this
way of life from what they're saying
that it's about worshiping one guy just
him not his creation they like all the
different things that they're starting
to learn about the last and final
messenger sent to mankind what advice do
you have for them now they're hearing
this and they're like wow this is you
know something also another detail to it
what advice do you have for those people
so they can take that step forward and
do what all the messengers of God did
submit to the one guy first of all a
person would be open-minded
yeah n would be sincere with himself
that he is looking for the truth with
open mind it would open heart and he
would start making the search and if a
person can begin with looking into the
biography of the Prophet Muhammad Sawa's
Allah or reading directly from the holy
crap let me just tell you how fear this
book is the book the final message that
was sent with Muhammad peace be upon him
that the only chapter that has a name of
a woman this name of woman is Mary the
mother of Jesus peace be upon him wow
it's not the mother of the Prophet
Muhammad it's not the wife of the
Prophet Muhammad it's not the daughter
of the Prophet SAW Muhammad rather it is
the mother of Jesus peace be upon a
whole chapter one of the biggest and
longest chapters in the Quran is about
Mary and I ask everybody to go to the
Quran and read that and see how fair
this book is to Mary the mother of Jesus
peace be upon him we're going to take a
break and we'll be right back on the D
show so little time on some of these
wonderful talking's and we're having I'm
sure as many were just enjoying
listening to you and tell us you know
closing comments and you've written
about ten books tell us a little bit
where people can go to get some of your
books and to see a little more of your
lectures and thank you one way is to
access the internet under Islam from A
to Z that come slam from A to Z calm
this is an easy way to access to have an
access to my books and to my works and i
will come any comments from the people
and you will find there my email which
is mamadora 2000 hotmail com people can
also see you on peace TV absolutely is
yeah okay thank you very much we look
forward to seeing you back here on the
Dean show thank you thank you thank you
God Almighty Allah reward you like a
love being with us and thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Dean
shot I hope you enjoyed this week's show
please make sure to come back here we're
here every week
same time same Channel until next time
Salaam alaikum peace be unto you I want
to be learning in a shape on your maji
miss Hilda him one mana Wahine enough
hijo mr. Moretti while only 150 laughing
lady one I heard he not only little bad
inna allaha ya'muru dunno beam where the
[ __ ] young univ ii hope is summer
wedding one on banana haha
so the Hanukkah femina come and see what
everyone's talking about who you find
one contradiction it can't be from God's
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guide is why I will never
give up spending this message hope there
you take that necessary stuff you don't
know if you're gonna live till tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now the reality of
life usually doesn't sink in until
tragedy commas you get a few bad people
the media grabs ahold of that and spends
it the way they want to if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his men you cannot be
a Muslim is that ended our faith to its
cold Italy everybody sleeping I arise
and ask a lot of thinking me Omar you
see hola you know all the sins I do I
turn to you to figure my sing tomorrow
I'm you seen for slave you're my love
runs away Oleg I me